(light organ music)
- [Johnny] Joseph Smith,
he's someone I know well.
He's the author of a worldview
that I held for most of my life.
I taught it to hundreds of
people when I was a missionary.
It's a religion and a gospel
that I deeply believed it.
One full of hope and meaning
and community and unique stories.
Stories about where we came
from and where we're going.
Let me show you what Joseph
Smith built and how he did it.
How a non-religious, uneducated
kid in upstate New York
created a global movement
that would gather huge numbers
of followers in a very short
time and who were pushed out
from town to town, often with violence.
I wanna show you how these
people held onto the vision
and mission that Joseph
Smith taught, the building
of a new utopian society, one
founded on celestial laws,
one that was preparing
for the end of the world
and the second coming of Jesus Christ.
So let me tell you the
story of Joseph Smith,
the church he built,
and how that church and its
mission still exists today.
- [Speaker 1] It's okay, a
missionary and everyone's happy.
- Hey, before we open up
this large can of worms
that I've been thinking
about for many years,
I want to thank the
sponsor of today's video,
the people who make this all possible.
Thank you BetterHelp for
sponsoring today's video.
BetterHelp is kind of
relevant to today's video
because BetterHelp is
a platform for therapy.
A few years ago I started
seeing a therapist every week,
not because I had some
clinical mental health issue
that I was trying to address,
but rather because I wasn't feeling good,
I knew there was things
in my life that I needed
to work through and there
are professionals for that.
Going to therapy has changed my mind.
It has changed my life,
it has changed how I see the world
and it has made my life
better, very objectively.
BetterHelp is a platform
that makes therapy more
accessible to more people.
You sign up for
BetterHelp, you take a quiz
that kind of tells them
a little bit about you
and your needs and your
goals, and then they match you
with a professional licensed therapist
that you can start communicating
with in as little as 48 hours.
You can have your therapy
sessions as a phone call,
as a video chat,
or even as a text message
if you prefer that,
if that's the most comfortable
version of therapy for you.
If your therapist isn't a good fit,
you can change to a
different therapist for free.
With access to BetterHelp's
growing network
of professional licensed therapists,
they have like tens of thousands
of different therapists.
You can find somebody who's
the right fit for you.
All of this makes finding a
therapist much more frictionless
than the traditional methods.
A major supporter of that
goal because I believe therapy
is a life changer, at least it was for me.
So there's a link in my description.
It's BetterHelp.com/JohnnyHarris.
When you click that link,
you help support the channel.
You also get 10% off your your
first month of BetterHelp.
So you can try it out at a
discount, see if it fits for you.
So I'm grateful to
BetterHelp for existing,
but also for sponsoring today's video.
With that, let's dive back into this.
Let's talk about the prophet Joseph Smith.
Joseph Smith was born in the perfect place
at the perfect time.
It was the early 1800s and
the U.S. had just thrown off
England to become a new country,
and it was going through
some massive growing pains.
Most of these new Americans who
had just left the old world,
rejected a lot of old world
things, namely religion.
Only 10% of white Americans regularly
attended church at this time.
So to help revive God,
you have all these super
charismatic preachers who left
the cities and went out to
the countryside to preach.
And this led to an explosion
of religious thought,
especially in upstate New York.
So now you have all these
like hyper reformist religions
that were replacing old style,
authoritarian type churches.
All these new wild religious flavors
that were more emotional,
expressive and personal.
I mean, none of us were
alive at this time,
but you can kind of imagine
like this brand new country
founded on these new ideals.
It was unprecedented times.
America felt special and different,
but also kind of scary.
Revolution in the new world,
new science, magical
technology, new ideas,
both wholesome and sinful,
all of it speeding up
at an increasing rate.
For a lot of people this was a sign,
a sign that the end of
the world was coming
and that Jesus, like he prophesied,
would come back to usher in
this thousand years of glory
for those who believed in him.
And a thousand years of
fire, for those who didn't.
This was called the Millennium.
So a lot of these new churches
that were cropping up kind
of claimed to be the place
that was preparing the
earth for the second coming,
like they were God's chosen
administrators on the earth
in the final days before it all ended.
It was scary, it was exciting,
and God was talking to
people again in new ways.
And this is the context that
Joseph Smith was born into.
In 1805, born to a mother who was swept up
in the excitement of
all these new religions
and a father who wasn't
really religious at all.
It was kind of like a lot
of people at the time,
a family that was religiously
lost, but not for long.
(suspenseful music)
In addition to being a
frothy religious environment,
upstate New York was also a place
where people hunted for treasure.
There was this culture
of folk magic and legends
that led to the search
for riches and jewels
that were potentially
buried by Spanish explorers
or pirates of the past or artifacts
that were hidden in Native
American burial mounds.
And their methods for
hunting for all this treasure
were mystical and magical.
They used seer stones, crystals, rods,
visions through dreams,
all of this to help them
locate buried treasure.
And young Joseph Smith was very caught up
in this treasure hunting craze.
He wasn't educated, he
barely had any schooling
he could kind of read and write.
He wasn't religious, but from a young age
he showed himself as a
skilled treasure hunter.
I mean, let's keep some perspective.
In all of our research,
we didn't find a single
like document showing
that he actually found any treasure,
but he managed to convey
to the people around him
that he was an expert treasure hunter,
using mythical methods.
So this is the context that
you need to know to really
understand this story.
We're in upstate New
York in the early 1800s.
There is this frenzy of folk
magic and treasure hunting,
and the place is a blaze
with religious fervor.
And there's talk of the last days
and the millennium of fire and glory
that was coming any day now.
But the story really begins
in the spring of 1820.
(birds chirpy)
(folksy music)
Joseph, a 14 year old boy
gets curious about religion.
And after visiting a bunch of churches
and finding no answers,
he decides to go into a
grove of trees to ask God,
which church was true.
This movie that we're watching right now,
I know by heart because I've
watched it hundreds of times,
of course, dubbed in Spanish.
I was a missionary in Tijuana,
and the first thing
that I would teach people was this story.
And I would often show them this movie.
- [Joseph Smith] I kneeled
down and began to offer up
the desires of my heart.
- So Joseph Smith is in this grove
and he's praying and after
a run in with the devil.
- [Joseph Smith] Exerting all
my strength to call upon God.
(suspenseful music)
- He sees a pillar of light,
brighter than the sun
directly over his head.
And within that light,
he sees two people whose
brightness defy all description.
He finds out that it's God the Father
and his son, Jesus Christ.
And Jesus goes on to tell
him that none of the churches
that he's been investigating are true
and that instead Joseph is being called
to do the work of God, to
restore the real true church
that had been lost from the earth.
To restore this church,
to prepare the world for
the second coming of Jesus
and the millennium that he will usher in.
This event is referred
to as the first vision
and it is the founding
story of the LDS Church,
The Mormon Church, like
most people know it.
As a member of the church
from a very young age
you learn this story,
you sing about it, you talk
about it, you study it,
and every few years the church comes out
with a new video version
representing the first vision.
Okay, so this is just the beginning.
A few years go by, Joseph
doesn't tell anyone
about his vision, but by 1823,
Joseph is a late teenager
and one night he's sleeping
in his like little humble
cabin with his family
and he says that an angel appears to him.
The angel is named Moroni.
By the way, if you ever
see a Mormon temple,
big white building, you
will see a depiction
of the angel Moroni on the top of
that temple with a trumpet pointing east.
But for now, he's an angel
in Joseph Smith's room
telling young Joseph that,
yes, the second coming
of Christ is right around
the corner and that yes,
just like God and Jesus
told him a few years ago,
he has been called to prepare the world
for the second coming.
And if that wasn't enough,
Moroni tells him that there
is a book that is written
on golden plates that is buried
in a hill near Joseph's house.
The book is an important
record of a group of Jews
who left Jerusalem in 600
BC and came to the Americas.
Anyway, I'll explain that in just a second
"And don't worry," says
Moroni, "along with the plates,
there's the gear you need to translate
these plates into English."
Joseph just needs to get a bit older
and he'll be ready to
translate the plates.
At this point, Joseph tells his
family what's been happening
and they believe him.
So by the time he's 21, he's
instructed to go to the hill,
Cumorah, near his house
and get the plates.
Okay, so now Joseph Smith in his twenties,
he's this uneducated,
unreligious, treasure hunter,
and he starts to focus in
on something totally new.
In the words of one believing Mormon
historian Richard Bushman,
"He starts to orient
himself away from treasure
and towards translation",
he's becoming a prophet.
(suspenseful music)
So Joseph says he goes
and gets these plates
and people try to rob him,
but eventually he gets them secured.
And in a little cabin in rural New York,
Joseph begins the work
of translating this stack
of metal plates that no
one else is allowed to see.
(suspenseful music)
He would sit on one side of a curtain
so that no one else could see,
and he says he looked through these stones
at the Egyptian engravings
on these golden plates,
and they would turn into English,
and then he would dictate
them out loud to a scribe,
sometimes his wife or other
early believers who were
supporting him and that
scribe would write them down.
At other points,
Joseph didn't even need
the plates to translate.
He could hide them somewhere else
and he would use his personal seer stone,
the one that he used back when
he was just a treasure hunter
before he says he was called as a prophet,
this little chocolate
colored egg shaped stone.
He would put it into a hat and
then he would bury his face
in the hat and he said that
the stone would light up
with the word that he was
supposed to dictate to his scribe.
His scribe would write it down
and the Book of Mormon was being written.
Now listen, all of this seems really weird
and wild to us now,
very easily like, okay,
clearly this guy's making it up,
but at the time, mystical
visions and treasure hunting
and seer stones, this was
all very normal in society.
Folk magic, native American artifacts,
none of this was very fringe.
And Joseph, Joseph had been doing stuff
like this for a decade,
which is why his parents
and other people in his
community supported him.
The difference though at this time is
that he was blending his
treasure hunting skills
and his folk magic sensibilities
with this religious revival
that was happening at the time to create
something kind of unique.
(birds chirping)
So anyway, he's in his early twenties,
he's translating the Book of Mormon.
He faces a bunch of ups and downs,
he goes through a few scribes and after
a very productive 90
day window, 24 year old,
barely educated Joseph Smith
finishes dictating 588 pages
of text that would become
the Book of Mormon.
(birds chirping)
Joseph says that he gives
the plates back to Moroni
and then takes the manuscript
of the pages to a printer.
That's how we have the Book of Mormon.
This is my Book of Mormon.
Maps, my early exposure to maps.
(pages turning)
So the Book of Mormon is
incredibly important to this story
because it was the main
validator for Joseph Smith
in those early days and continues
to be a foundational part
for believers in the LDS faith.
That's because Joseph Smith
wasn't religious or educated
and now suddenly he's
writing this Bible like book
in a few months.
And yes, this book is
definitely full of a lot
of like full blown copy and
paste jobs from like the Bible.
But there's also like a lot
of really compelling stuff in
here in terms of religious
lessons, complex histories,
nods back to like an understanding
of Hebrew language and culture.
This is not the type of guy
that his town saw him as.
He was a treasure hunter and a farm kid,
not a religious man, and
definitely not a prophet.
- [Speaker 2] Mr. Smith,
could you tell me more
about that book?
- Yes, yes, I could.
- Okay, so let's be clear
on what Joseph Smith said
The Book of Mormon is, it's
not what a lot of people say,
which is like the Mormon Bible.
The book tells the story of
a group of Jews in Jerusalem
in around 600 BC.
They're told to leave the city
before it gets destroyed.
So they leave the city, they
walk in the desert for a while,
probably to like Oman is
what a lot of Mormons think.
And then they build a boat
and travel across the ocean
for a very long time until
they reach the Americas,
somewhere in like North
Central or South America.
The foundation of the story
is about these brothers
of the original family who
like eventually split off
and they like hate each
other and they grow up into
these two different civilizations,
the Nephites and the Lamanites
who are always fighting
with each other.
And there's all these prophets
and there's all this drama that happens.
And the introduction to
my Book of Mormons says,
"The Lamanites", these people
came over from Jerusalem,
are quote "the principle ancestors
of the American Indians."
And a few years ago they did
change that to, "The Lamanites
being among the ancestors
of the American Indians."
But yeah, the point is
that the Book of Mormon
is a history of these Jews
turned indigenous Americans.
And unsurprisingly, there's a
whole community of believers
who work to validate
that this is actually a historic record.
But no, in the reality there's
no archeological, genetic,
or linguistic evidence that
supports the Book of Mormon's
assertion that Jewish people migrated
to the Americas around 600 BC.
For believers, the most
important part of this book
is the climax of the whole thing,
where in 33 AD Jesus, having
recently been crucified
over in the old world, in Jerusalem,
gets resurrected over there
and comes to visit the people in America,
which is where this painting came from.
This is a painting that is hanging
in a lot of LDS churches.
It shows Jesus Christ among
the ancient civilizations
of the Americas.
Yeah, some pretty wild stories.
(suspenseful music)
(birds chirping)
So yeah, I know we're all over the place
and we'll get back to Joseph
Smith's life for a second.
But as someone who has read
this book dozens of times,
I can tell you that
when you're a believer,
this is a really compelling piece of work.
You can read these pages and
you can read about the stories
and the lessons and the metaphors
and you can take a lot from it.
And the biggest thing that
you take from it is that
it is proof that Joseph Smith
was actually called of God
to prepare the world
for the second coming,
that he was a legitimate prophet.
So Joseph Smith by 1830
has the Book of Mormon.
He has proof that he's a prophet
and he starts to gain followers,
followers that believe him.
And a group of those followers
get together in April of 1830
in a little house in Fayette, New York,
and they start a church.
At this point, Joseph Smith is behaving
like a full-blown prophet.
He says he's getting almost
daily communication from Jesus
and he starts to develop a theology
that is unlike anything else on offer.
(light piano music)
Turns out that God is actually
a man with a body of flesh
and bone and he has a wife.
God lives near a star that's far away.
And we, all of us here on
earth, are these little
eternal balls of light
called intelligences,
but are heavenly parents have birthed us
into spiritual children.
And then they sent us down onto this earth
to get a physical body, to get married,
to create an earthly family,
to learn and to grow.
So that someday we can
return to live with God,
with our families,
and then we can become
like God with our spouses.
We can create our own spiritual families
in some other part of the
universe, but in order to do that,
we have to pass some tests here on earth.
We have to complete certain rituals
and demonstrate obedience to him.
And in order to make this all happen,
he needs to set up a church.
The church needs to have proper authority
and there would need to be a savior
that would come down to
account for all of our sins
so that we can be pure to enter
the Kingdom of God, again.
Luckily, one of our spiritual
brothers named Jehovah later
called Jesus volunteered
to be this savior.
Okay, but there's a big problem,
which is that God's children
are super rebellious.
So over the years, God calls prophets
to organize his church
with the proper authority
and to do all of these special rituals
to teach them about Jesus.
And eventually that truth
gets eroded and it fades away
and the world falls into
apostasy until it's ready again.
When God calls another prophet
to restore his authority
and start the whole process over again,
this happens over and over.
Until eventually Jesus came,
he was like the sixth prophet.
He establishes his church
causes prophets and apostles
gives them the authority by
putting his hands on their head.
And then of course he suffers for our sins
and dies on the cross.
But just like has happened over and over,
Jesus' church got corrupted,
it got mixed with power and politics
and the world fell back into the apostasy.
This one's called the great apostasy.
But eventually the world
would be coming to an end.
Jesus would be coming soon
and things were about to get really bad.
So God helped Europeans
come across the ocean
to take over North America,
colonize the land, and create a country
that had freedom of religion.
Also, that a few decades later,
Joseph Smith could be born
and then called to restore his church.
And that's how we get to the first vision.
Jesus and heavenly Father
appearing to Joseph Smith
in a grove, sending angels
to him to tell him where
to get the golden plates.
And to solve for the
whole authority thing,
Joseph says that the apostles,
the original apostles of
Jesus Christ came to him
to restore the authority that priesthood
that Jesus had given them.
So now he could establish his church.
There was a restoration,
Joseph was the prophet of
a newly restored church
that he could talk to God,
he could get instruction on
exactly how to run God's Kingdom
here on earth to prepare the
world for the millennium.
Okay, that was a lot.
And lemme just say that was
a very summarized version
of LDS theology.
Someday I'd like to make
a video about the details
because it's actually super
complex and super wild.
The point I'm trying to make here is
that Joseph Smith's church
did indeed have a lot
of the ingredients of the
religious movements of the time,
last days, apocalypse preparing
God's Kingdom on the earth,
preparing for the millennium.
This was all trending at the time.
This was not surprising.
But a lot of this stuff was totally new,
wild fringe doctrine.
God has a body and a wife.
This was a completely wild
blend of Jewish mysticism,
American folk magic,
reincarnation, evangelical Christianity.
And eventually he even woven freemasonry.
A totally fresh thing.
There was nothing quite like it.
It was super unique and super
potent and super polarizing.
You either believed that Joseph Smith
was an incredibly inspired
prophet who was like revealing
the truth that none of
us had ever heard before,
or he was just a brilliant,
creative visionary
inventing this elaborate
plan to dupe people,
which is what a lot of
people in his village
started to think as he
started to gain followers.
They had him arrested, calling
him a disorderly person.
He eventually gets
released and he realizes
that he and his few members need to leave.
(organ music)
This begins the long journey
of the Mormons moving west.
Joseph and his followers set out.
He's now talking to God
directly all of the time,
and he says that the Lord
is telling him to go to Ohio
to await instructions for
their actual final destination,
the place that they're actually
gonna set up their new city,
their millennial kingdom,
this communal utopian society
that would be the base
for preparing the world for
the second coming of Jesus.
They would call it Zion.
And this is the most important part of
the entire story, Zion.
If you want to understand Joseph Smith,
and if you want to understand the rest
of the Latter-day Saints movement,
including modern Mormonism,
you have to understand Zion.
(suspenseful music)
Joseph says that the Lord is telling him
that he will give him the
exact location of Zion,
and he tells him that it
will be quote "On the borders
by the Lamanites".
Remember that the Lamanites
are the American Indians.
And so this actually works perfectly
because at this time, the U.S. government
is ethnically cleansing North America
and pushing first Americans west.
So there's a lot of territory
where white settlers
are budding up against Native Americans.
Zion's gonna be somewhere around here.
So Joseph and his
followers are now in Ohio
and they are growing.
People love this story.
And the concept of Zion transitions
from this sort of vague,
idealistic idea to a very solid plan.
A new society called the new Jerusalem,
the new Jerusalem from
the prophecies of old.
And it literally became a plan,
like he actually starts
to sketch it on paper.
We got these digital scans
of Joseph Smith's sketches of Zion.
(light piano music)
He writes in extreme detail on exactly
what this city will be.
This whole thing was based
on these gridded streets,
on perfectly parceled plots,
on no more than one square mile of land.
Joseph writes that "The
home should be 25 feet
from the street to leave room
for a yard and plant gardens.
All the houses were to be
brick or brick and stone,
and there should be farms
all around this city
that aren't too far."
The central streets of this
city nod to Joseph's love
for Jewish history and culture.
Zion Street, Jerusalem
Street, Bethlehem Street,
with the temple in the center of the city.
Spoiler alert, this is how Salt Lake City
and a lot of cities in
Utah are actually designed.
But that's for part two.
I mean, what this shows is that
Joseph was taking this idea
of God's restored kingdom on
earth, totally, literally.
And it was gonna be hyper progressive,
a new communal society
where everyone would share
with one another, the
resources would be shared,
and the whole thing would be
governed by celestial laws
and governmental structures.
A new government run by
the prophet where God
could talk to his people
while he prepared the world for its end.
Zion was a vision that
Joseph was uniquely good
at rallying around.
Charismatic and creative
leader, prolific and inspiring.
His followers became deeply dedicated
to this mission of establishing Zion,
and it becomes the main
calling card for new converts.
Joseph Smith's Millennial
Kingdom is the place to be
when the world ends,
and the world's ending any day now.
(light upbeat music)
So the church is growing in Ohio.
They still don't know where
the final location of Zion
is gonna be, and meanwhile,
Joseph is getting more and more
and more of these revelations,
and he's pushing the
belief system of Mormonism
further and further from
mainstream Christianity.
Joseph comes out and says there actually
is no heaven and hell,
but rather there are
three kingdoms of heaven.
All of us will be sorted
into these different kingdoms
depending on how obedient
we were here on earth,
how much we accepted Christ
and repented of our sins.
There's even a spiritual
prison and paradise
that you go to after you die,
but before you're sorted
into the kingdoms.
In order to get to the
highest degree of kingdom,
the celestial kingdom,
you have to be married
by the proper authority
that will seal you to you and
your family forever and soon.
Joseph says that more
angels are appearing to him
to give him the authority
to do this sealing thing.
Family is becoming core
to Mormon theology.
But the good times don't last.
The locals in Ohio and
their government don't love
this vision of a new religious society.
The flocks of new members
of the church arriving
to this super well-organized, efficient,
unified group of people led
by this charismatic prophet
who has more and more fringe beliefs.
One night Joseph is violently dragged
from his home by a mob.
He's covered in tar and feathers.
They're telling him to leave and he does.
Luckily, one of Joseph's missionaries
and former scribes Oliver
Cowdery had been out scouting
where Zion should be,
where the millennial
kingdom should be set up.
And he comes back and
says he found the place,
Jackson County, Missouri, 800 miles away.
Indeed and just as the Lord said,
right on the border with the Laymanites.
"This would be Zion",
the Lord tells Joseph,
the place where he is appointed
for the gathering of the saints.
And now there's a revelation
from the Lord saying
that all of this land in Independence,
Missouri should be
purchased by the saints.
Buy up as much land as you can.
This is Zion.
Oh, and it is revealed
to Joseph that this area,
Independence, Missouri,
Jackson County, Missouri,
is right next to the
original Garden of Eden
like where Adam and Eve
like the first people were.
It turns out that Missouri
is like the holy land,
the epicenter for the end of the world,
and the Garden of Eden is in Missouri.
So Mormons start buying up land
and they start moving to Missouri.
And they did this quickly.
This wasn't theoretical.
They thought that the second
coming was like weeks or months
or just maybe a few years away.
Martin Harris, one of the early converts,
asserted that quote, "In four years,
every religion in the
U.S. would be broken down
and all would become Mormon,
and that the rest of the
human race would just perish."
And then he was so confident that he said
that "If it didn't happen, he
would cut off his own hands."
I mean, they were serious
about building Zion in Missouri and quick.
Okay, but not so fast.
The locals like are not into this.
They hear about this swarm of
Mormons coming to their county
who want to turn their
city into a new religious,
communal society and
prepare for the apocalypse.
And now they're arriving by the thousands,
which means they will have
more political power soon.
They start to get scared
that the Mormons are plotting
a takeover of their private
property all in the name
of building Zion, and they're
not gonna stand for it.
They want the Mormons out.
So they start sabotaging
them with violence,
vandalizing their stores,
destroying their homes,
assaulting Mormon leaders.
It gets really violent.
And at first, Joseph tells his
followers to not fight back.
And once again, the
Mormons are driven out.
The next five years are
years of conflict for Joseph
and his growing church.
They're on the move all over the Midwest,
at each stop facing violent resistance
from local residents and
government officials.
So Joseph and his followers
are done being passive.
They start fighting back and it escalates
into basically a full blown war.
The governor of Missouri issues
a literal extermination
order saying quote,
"The Mormons must be treated as enemies
and must be exterminated or driven
from the state if necessary
for public peace."
It's getting really bad.
So they flee once more to
Illinois where the government,
who includes a young lawmaker
named Abraham Lincoln,
gives them a special
charter to create a city
and a government that is fit
for their unique Zion principles.
They call this city Nauvoo,
Hebrew for beautiful or beautiful place.
(calm music)
Okay, so even though the Lord
had said to Joseph that he had
prepared Missouri to
be the place for Zion,
the Saints were gonna have to
settle for Illinois for now,
and they feel safe
protected by this charter
and they start creating Zion.
There's a total merger
between church and state,
a complete religiously run settlement
where Joseph appoints himself
to be in charge of the courts
as well as the newly strengthened militia.
They now have a full army
to protect themselves.
Joseph had been sending
missionaries to Europe to preach
about the gospel and invite people
to come join his vision of Zion.
And one of those people is my
like great-great-grandfather
who was converted by a
missionary in England
and then traveled to the
United States with his family
and pregnant wife in
pursuit of finding Zion.
And they arrived to Nauvoo,
a city that eventually grew
to be more populous than Chicago.
And it's in Nauvoo where Joseph says
that an angel appeared to him
and demanded, multiple times,
against his will, that he
take on multiple wives,
that those wives are sealed to him.
His first plural marriage is to a teenager
and he goes on to have 40
wives in just three years.
Many of them were married to other people,
but then were sealed
to Joseph the prophet.
What I find striking here
is that up until this point,
you have this meticulous
documentation of every single
revelation and theology rule
and new policy in the church
here in what's called
the doctrine covenants.
But polygamy stayed quiet and private.
It was one of those revelations
reserved for just Joseph
and the leaders that he chose.
By 1844, the Zion dream
is actually catching fire.
It's growing in Illinois,
and Joseph decides to run for president.
Now, he didn't have a
big chance of winning,
but in his mind and the
mind of his followers,
this was the natural next step.
They were establishing Zion,
and Zion was going to be
the new society on earth.
But this presidential
campaign miserably backfires
because now he has seen as a
legitimate political threat.
He's too good at gaining new followers.
It gets worse when one group
of former Latter-day Saints,
who didn't agree with Joseph decide
to publish a newspaper in
Nauvoo that criticized him
for polygamy and generally his leadership.
Joseph has done messing
around at this point.
He's become very militant,
and he responds by sending his militia
to destroy their printing press.
He declares martial law, and
now the government of Illinois
who had given them this
sort of safe charter,
sees this chaos and they're not into it.
And they arrest Joseph for
attempting to incite a riot.
Now, this was one of
many run-ins with the law
that Joseph Smith had didn't cover them.
Some of them were legitimate,
some of them were trumped up,
but now he's caused a real disruption.
He gets locked up in
jail and two days later,
a mob of more than 200
men storm this jail.
They climb up to the
second floor where Joseph
and his brother are,
and they shoot at him.
He tries to jump out the window
and he falls to his death.
The prophet is dead at 38.
(gun shots)
Joseph Smith is now a martyr.
He died with a Book of
Mormon in his hands,
defending his vision, his
belief in his own story.
This poured fuel on the
fire of his vision for Zion.
But the Latter-day Saints start to realize
that if they're gonna build Zion,
it's not gonna be in the United States.
They need to look further afoot.
They need a place far
away where they can build
their millennial kingdom
without being harassed for it.
So you look far to the west, to Mexico,
and the next chapter of the
story is the move into Mexico
and the establishment of their Zion
next to a large salty
lake in the high desert.
And that is a story I'll
tell you in part two.
But for now, I want to just tell you
my thoughts on Joseph Smith.
As someone who spent most of
my life believing this story,
basing my life and my worldview around it,
doing this story and looking
at it from an objective
historical lens has taught me a lot.
Joseph Smith created
something really powerful.
You can't deny that.
It was a story about the last days.
It was a story full of
treasure and visions and angels
and modern day revelation from God.
It was a story about a chosen people,
a utopian society of one heart
and one mind, safety, enlightenment.
There's a reason why every year,
Latter-day Saints go back to
that hill in upstate New York
where Joseph said he found the plates
and they put on this
insanely ambitious production
on a stage that's like 10 levels deep
with almost a thousand
characters where they reenact
the story of Joseph Smith, their prophet.
They reenact him finding the
plates, translating them,
and then they act out the
story of the Book of Mormon.
There's a reason why Latter-day
Saints sing a song called,
"Praise to the Man", where
they laud Joseph Smith,
the prophet who opened
the last dispensation,
who restored the truth to the world.
♪ Jesus anointed the prophet ♪
I believed this.
I believed this well into my twenties.
I found deep comfort in it.
I found community in
being a part of a religion
that was so different
than every other religion,
and that was very often mocked for it.
The martyrdom and the
persecution of Joseph
and his followers became
proof that this was true
and that it was being
persecuted in these last days,
just like the prophecies
in the Bible told us about.
And I was compelled by
this idea of the last days.
The problem with getting
caught up in the beauty
and the comfort, and the
narrative of being a chosen people
in the last days is that
it allows you to ignore.
I think that's what a lot
of people have done over
the decades with Joseph's story.
They ignore, they ignore something
that I guess is plain for me to see now,
on the other side of this.
(light piano music)
Brother, I am happy, happy man.
I've been for more than a missionary
for more than a year now, I can relax.
Joseph Smith was a charismatic
leader who knew how
to tell stories about
magic, about visions,
and about treasure.
He had known how to do that
since he was a teenager.
Well before he decided he was
going to become a prophet.
He found an audience in doing this.
He attracted people to him
with his visionary skills,
and he used those skills to
invent a complex set of stories
about Native Americans
actually being Israelites,
about heavenly parents,
preparing the world for its end
and about the priesthood,
this authority that we all
must participate in to receive
the rituals and ordinances
that only one church can administer.
And eventually, he used these
stories to build a movement
around his vision that
allowed him to take 40 wives
and build an army and break
laws and bully his enemies.
When you are a Latter-day Saint,
these facts are written off
as anti-Mormon literature or persecution.
But for me, having left
the church and spent years
rewiring my brain and my
programming of these stories,
I see them as facts.
And frankly, they're not that surprising.
This is the same old story of
a charismatic, visionary man
who tells a story of apocalyptic endings
to gain followers, to gain power,
and then decides that he
deserves a lot of women,
and then he dies for the cause,
leaving a movement that
continues his vision.
Oftentimes those movements
get more and more dogmatic.
They use shame to keep
their people close to them,
and they revere their prophet long after
that prophet is dead.
And yet, what's complicated
about this is I can't help,
but feel a deep sense of sadness
for having lost my belief
in Joseph's story.
I can't explain it,
but these stories are
incredibly comforting
when you believe in
them, they're motivating.
These creative stories unlike
any other belief system
can be really beautiful.
And that is a paradox that
there's really no resolution for.
There's a lot more to say on this,
but I'm gonna save it for
part two on the series
where we see what happens
next after Joseph is murdered
and the Latter-day Saints move west
to find their vision of Zion, okay.
(birds chirping)
(light calm music)
Okay, well, thanks for watching.
And if you're still here,
I know that was a bit of
a emotional rollercoaster
there at the end,
especially if you are
someone who was associated
with the church in any way.
And there's a lot there.
And I know in making this video,
I felt a lot of feelings and
rehashed a lot of things,
but I think doing it,
telling this story has been
pretty cathartic for me,
and I'm really looking
forward to the discussion
in the comments about what
others feel about this stuff.
Let me tell you about a couple things.
Number one, I'm really grateful
for those who support us
over at The Newsroom.
The Newsroom is what we call our Patreon.
It is a community of people who support
the independent journalism
we're doing here on the channel.
Newsroom members get an
extra video every month.
It's a vlog that is a
behind the scenes look at
what it's like to be here in
the studio with us running
this independent journalism
studio on YouTube,
which is a fun experiment.
You meet the people behind the scenes,
you see our processes,
you see our shenanigans.
It's a good time.
You also get access to my
scripts and some music.
But most importantly,
the people who are there are mostly there
because they believe in what we're doing
and they wanna support, which is awesome.
Also, I'm really into maps,
which is not new to many of you.
I designed a poster that
you can have on your wall.
It is called "All Maps Are Wrong",
and it displays like 96
different map projections,
the different ways that you
can show our spherical globe
on a flat plane.
So that is for sale.
I think we sold out,
but I think we've ordered a new batch.
So that should be for sale.
I hope it's for sale, I
hope it's not sold out.
If you're like a video photo person,
we have LUTs and presets,
which are just ways to color
your photos or your videos
the way that we color
our photos and videos.
We develop these with a
professional colorist.
They reflect kind of our look and feel.
You can buy those and support
the channel and use them.
At the end of the day, you
being here, commenting,
showing your support, showing your love,
watching these videos is the best way
that you can support us.
So I appreciate you being here,
and we're just gonna keep
making lots of videos.
Thanks for being here.
Talk to you later, bye.
Okay, we did it, dude.
(light upbeat music)